if you're going out to be a grip or an
electric
you know you go work on the avengers
well they're hiring a hundred grips
and they're hiring two writers
we had this comment come in the other
day under one of our videos and it's
the thing that no older quote successful
artist understands is that
just make it is not an option when you
are a young artist and have to work in a
cafe part-time to survive
you know i feel like
there's a lot of people that give that
advice just go out and make it go out
and make your thing
and
there's it's definitely a blessing and a
curse you know if you go out with your
friends and you make something that is
absolutely atrocious
that everyone thinks is funny but then
you show it to someone else and they're
kind of like well you can't show anybody
this is terrible it'll make you look bad
you don't want to do that at the
especially the beginning
and i had that situation out with one of
our projects where we did a whole proof
of concept and spent a lot of money and
did a lot of time and energy and work
and we did it the best we possibly could
and then we showed it to some bigger
people and they were like well this is
bad you can't show anyone this and it
was like oh
okay and we had to pull it you know we
had to recut it and tighten it up and
not show it to anyone because they were
like this is detrimental to your career
if you're looking to build a career off
of this this isn't going to help you out
and so at some point you have to
understand that too that if if you do
run into that situation
then you make a decision
but i mean
everything comes down to marketing you
can release a movie and not do any
marketing and the movie exists
but no one's seen it so they're probably
not gonna have watched it anyway when
you have it on your resume or you have
it on your imdb it's like oh yeah you
made all these movies i haven't seen
them but that's cool that you made those
movies
um
because if you're not marketing and
getting the word out that no one's gonna
watch it anyway especially so
i think that it's
it changes too nowadays it's gotten so
much cheaper and easier to make higher
quality content
i mean you look at you know a
professional camera package you can
probably get for under 10 grand now
whereas 20 years ago it would have been
200 grand
so
you can make good quality stuff nowadays
easier
but
everything has to be good quality to
make this ultimate movie that's really
going to impress people to launch you to
that next level and i think a lot of
people don't have the ability to do that
i mean i have friends in town that they
were like oh you have cameras and lights
and sound and i'm like oh yeah i've got
everything they're like oh wow because i
always wanted to make this video but i
have no way of doing it
and it's like well you find somebody
else that does have it and hopefully at
some point this is one of the good
benefits of film schools
i'm not a firm believer in film schools
um but
you want to find your your crew you want
to find your tribe and if there's a way
to build that a film school is the best
way to do that the school itself is
going to do whatever but it's finding
those other people that are like-minded
that maybe have equipment and you try to
build that up and especially now with
social media finding other people nearby
you is a lot easier
and seeing who is the camera who has
lights who's an actor and then trying to
put something together that hopefully
isn't horrible or you start doing
horrible things and say okay well this
is a good this was fun but now let's do
something better because every time you
do it it's only going to get better and
better and better hopefully
um and if it's not then maybe you should
look into a different career because uh
might not be for you
well and if you didn't go to a film
school you can still find your quote try
but i think it would take a little bit
longer but i mean you can you can meet
fantastic people on craigslist you can
meet also some scary people on
craigslist but you know or you could
find people on mandy or whatever and it
might just take longer to piece together
reliable people that you have the same
personality type you can work well
together you know
and i think it's definitely a stigma in
the industry
which i i don't disagree with nowadays
where it's kind of like hey
looking for a crew to make this movie
paying you in in lunch and imdb credit
and it's kind of like you know if i was
20 i'd have been like that's awesome i
want to totally jump on that guy's team
and do this but at 40 i'm kind of like
all right well what are you doing kid
like you know you need to pay those
people because they have rent and
families and
so it's definitely become a problem to
where our industry also doesn't really
put the value in what exactly we're
bringing to the table because i think a
lot so many people don't understand it
i always compare it to when i go get my
car fixed i have no idea how to fix a
car i have nowhere i don't know where
anything i barely can put the gasoline
and let alone know what the engine does
so it's like those guys are like well i
work for 80 an hour it's like okay
here's your 80 an hour go fix my car
because i have no idea what you're doing
but then when someone comes to a
filmmaker or a camera operator or
someone that's like oh yeah i work for
80 an hour and they're like
what are you talking about all you do is
press a button and like there's a
strange mentality around the industry
about that that devalues what exactly we
do and
you watch these big movies there's a
thousand people's names in the credits
it's like every single one of these
people had to do something to pull off
this thing you just watched for two
hours in your your living room um
so that stigma is unfortunate because it
the devaluing everything and telling
film school kids will go out and work
for free for the first 10 years and it's
like well how do you do that like that's
you kind of need to pay your bills and
survive
um but then you have to get better and
it's always a car before the horse story
it's like how do you get better if
you're not doing it but then people say
just go do it and
there's plenty of stories that someone
is successful from just doing it for
sure but it's a needle in a haystack and
that's going to happen a handful of
times a year with 10 000 people trying
but i mean a lot of this industry is is
luck
and talent i mean i like to think that
everyone has talent everyone's talented
in the industry
so if you start off at a sea of a
thousand people and every single one of
them's talented and three people are
going to get caught to move on
then it's luck
you know it's really luck
and networking like getting as many
people to know you exist as humanly
possible is like the real key to the
whole industry because you're literally
just floundering a sea of thousands
trying to have some be like hey i'm
really talented it's like well yeah
you're really talented that guy's
talented that girl's talented
everybody's talented everyone's good
especially here in los angeles it's like
they've made the jump they're here
they're strong they're ready to fight
for what they want
um
so it's definitely
there's definitely a lot of different
schools of thought around it and it's
trying to figure out what works best for
you and your situation is really the the
challenging one
um hopefully your
grandparents or the neighbor to someone
really famous and they can just make a
phone call and give you a career like
that's the easy way to do it
well even with that though they still
got to show up and they still have to
perform in some way so connections i
think do help
i've never had any but i have seen
people who have
and it doesn't always guarantee them
a job they still have to you know and
and sometimes and i i know people are
going to fight me on this when things
are too comfortable for certain people
for too long i think there's a lack of
willingness to try and that's what i was
my next question was that with certain
institutions and you say they they
advocate just you know working for free
or doing different things is that a very
textbook response
for people that have the money to go to
them community colleges i don't think
they would probably give that advice but
maybe they would i don't know i mean i
think
i would feel that and this is across the
board with all industries i mean
internships out of college or during
college is pretty consistent which is
free labor it's like you're working free
labor in the industry of your choice to
gain more real world experience
and that happens everywhere that happens
with doctors it happens with i mean
almost any industry you you still go
into a residency you still have to go do
the or do internships with corporations
to try to get into those positions you
want because you have to prove yourself
that you're talented and qualified to be
able to move up in the world
and that so i do agree that it's the
same way in film it's like if you're in
college and you're trying to get more
experience i mean i internship when i
was in high school and summoned during
college and i got great experience and i
met lots of new people and it definitely
helped me out
but it's more so the you're going to be
working for free for 10 years or the
expectation that everyone else should
work for free for 10 years that's that's
where it gets frustrating because
everyone's creative and everyone wants
to do stuff and it's a lot of fun to do
things and it's awesome i mean if i
could be on set every day i would but
at a point a certain point you have to
kind of decide like okay now i'm
working beyond my worth like i need to
actually make money and i need to
survive and support my family and so you
have to figure out what's the best way
to do that
but i think that internships is a very
common
rule across the board of any any
occupation
and and it's advised from any college
yeah whether whether like a prestigious
four-year or
a local community college which could
have just as great
of a teacher it could be the same
teacher actually yeah
i mean some schools offer placement um
some schools have great reputations for
getting people jobs out of college
and so it all kind of depends i mean in
the writing directing world
those are the two hardest jobs to get in
the industry if you're going out to be a
grip or an electric
you know you go work on the avengers
well they're hiring a hundred grips
and they're hiring two writers
for that for one movie so it's like
there's lots of other opportunities you
get into a below the line position
you're a production assistant or makeup
or
you know yeah g e there's a ton more
work because they hire so many more of
those jobs and i have friends that just
went to those and they're like oh they
they're booked for years because they're
so much opportunity there
but for someone that wants to be a
little more creative that focuses on
writing and directing or something
there's way less of those jobs
and
i remember in 2009 i did a short film
that got a lot of acclaim called 222. it
was a graphic horror short and we were
getting calls from all over the place
new line cinema called up and i was in
florida being like oh crap like we made
a good short oh no what do we do now i
remember meeting with a management firm
here
and we had a whole meeting and they were
like well what do you want to do with it
and i'm like what do you mean
they're like well why'd you make the
short i was like well i wanted a calling
card to show what my abilities were to
try to raise more awareness and they're
like oh you don't want to turn this into
a movie and i'm like i mean we we
couldn't turn it into a movie they're
like oh you don't have a script ready to
go and i'm like
no
and they're like oh all right well
thanks for coming by you know and i was
like wait what what happened i didn't
get this lesson
and i were talking to one of the
managers
and i was like okay so you're not you're
not going to sign me
but can i ask why like i just i'm
curious this is all new to me and he was
like look we represent joel schumacher
if this is back in 2009 we represent
joel schumacher we send him into
meetings to try to get directing jobs
so when it's you and joe schumacher joel
schumacher in a meeting or they have to
decide between the two of you who do you
think they're going to choose and i'm
like oh well joel schumacher obviously
and they're like yeah that's the problem
is that we can't put you next to joel
schumacher yet
like you need to do something big enough
to be like oh this guy just did this oh
okay that's who that is
and so it's the same kind of a thing
like you're constantly proving yourself
all the way up the ladder
even though i mean i've pitched a dozen
major studios in town now you know i
haven't gotten any yeses yet but i've
got open door policies and i'm in there
and working the game and everything
and so
it's exciting just to be part of the
system and figure out how the mechanisms
work and everything but until something
happens or i get a lucky break or
something that breaks you out of that
it's uh it's a lot more challenging for
sure
and now do you have answers ready for
their questions like the magical what do
you what else do you have oh every
single project i do i do for a very
specific purpose especially shorts
if you make a short film there's usually
three reasons you make a short film one
is to do something fun with your friends
two is to take it to film festivals and
try to win awards or three use it to try
to make a feature to try to get you know
to raise enough awareness and show your
capabilities at a zero budget or low
budget that we could do on a feature
level
so i feel like every project should be
like that at this point that you make a
project for a very specific reason i
mean every now and then you get a for
hire job like there's a new short that i
just signed on to that's just a
directing for hire and it's a company
that wants us to do this for them and
i'm like sure you know you can that can
totally produce your content as well
um but i think you need to have a plan
because if you do catch that lighting in
a bottle
you need to know what to do with it and
i was definitely i'm really curious if i
had everything prepared back then what
would have happened because now when i
make a script i do a full breakdown i do
concept art i do a poster art for every
single project i'm pitching so it's like
here's this there's one that i'm really
in love with i did a full brand package
we developed a comic book and a video
game app and everything it's like look
this is the whole brand this is the
marketing this is how we would do it
and then you shop it that way which is a
lot better than well i've got an idea
or i've got a script
and that's it you know you kind of at
this point need to do a little bit more
leg work to be able to showcase what you
can do and some people do hypercut
trailers you know you go make a trailer
with a bunch of other footage
this is the feel that we're going for
kind of a thing or or concept art or
whatnot um
but yeah it's i mean it's a challenge no
matter what it's all an uphill battle so
the more you're prepared for it the
better